DAVE DAY: Hi.
Good morning everyone, and
welcome to Empowering Your
Business with Google Maps.
My name's Dave Day.
And this is my good friend,
David Owens.
And today we're excited to be
sharing with you some of the
projects we've been working
on in the Google Maps
team down in Sydney.
So the question we're trying to
answer in today's session
is a pretty broad one.
Where's my stuff?
It's a broad one.
But for businesses today, it's
an increasingly crucial one.
And it transcends that age old
question of where did I leave
my car keys?
For businesses today,
it's more about
where are my people?
Where are my vehicles?
Where are the packages that I'm
delivering through my system?
And even once I know where they
are, what are they doing?
And how can I help them
be more effective?
So even though it's an important
question today, as
time goes on it's going
to become an even
more important question.
By 2015, it is projected there
will be 1.3 billion mobile
workers out there
in the world.
That's a huge number.
And it represents more
than 1/3 of the
entire global workforce.
And so we will have to be
answering questions like, how
can I get my taxi driver
to her next fare?
How can I get my plumber
to a leaking tap?
How can I get my sales people
and my engineers out of my
office and into my clients'
offices so they can sit down
and help them?
How can I get one of my founding
members onto a sky
plane so he can skydive onto
the Moscone Center.
And even though the questions
are increasing, the tools that
are at our disposal are also
going to be increasing too.
I'm sure there's not a single
person listening here today
who doesn't have in their hand
or in their pocket an internet
enabled device already.
In fact, almost 2/3 of mobile
workers are carrying around a
tablet throughout the day.
And they're spending almost
2/3 of that day in the
presence of a Wi-Fi network.
And so with that in mind, in
an attempt to answer these
questions, today we're going to
be talking about two paid
enterprise products
to help solve that
question, where's my stuff?
First, Dave will be walking
through the new Google Maps
Coordinate project.
And then I'll be taking a look
at how we have exposed the
powerful infrastructure behind
Google Maps Coordinate for
developers in the Google
Maps Tracks API.
DAVID OWENS: Thanks, Dave.
Good morning, everybody.
My name is David Owens.
As Dave said, I'm here to talk
to you about Google Maps
Coordinate.
So let's go back to here.
Thank you.
And go to Google Maps
Coordinate.
What is Google Maps
Coordinate?
Google Maps Coordinate is a
mobile and web application
that helps enterprises manage
their mobile workforce.
That's as clean as
I can say it.
There's also an API to this.
Let's talk about it
a little bit more.
It is a tool that includes job
management functionality,
communications functionality.
It's enhanced by real
time location.
And it's all presented
on a Google map.
In the context of our where's my
stuff question, Google Maps
Coordinate organizes your stuff,
whatever it may be,
into two different categories.
First, jobs.
This is work to be done.
It could be sales calls to make,
trees to trim, telephone
poles that need retrofitting.
It could be corporate security
incidents that need to be
followed up on, whatever
work needs get done.
Secondly, we have a team.
And this is the set of people
who together work together to
get that work done.
Now a lot of the people on
this team are going to be
those people that Dave mentioned
before, those 1.3
billion mobile workers, who
are out there retrofitting
those poles, or dropping
off the [INAUDIBLE]
supplies that have been
requested, or checking up on
the security incidents.
But then also includes
dispatchers, who play a
critical role, and
administrators, just like in
any kind of system.
Great.
So there are three primary
interfaces that we're going to
talk about today for Google
Maps Coordinate.
I'll go over them quickly.
And then we'll go over them in
more detail in a little while.
First-- and these are
overlaid here--
I've got a web UI
at the bottom.
It says Google Maps Coordinate
up at the top.
And that's our primary tool
for the administrators and
dispatchers to do their work.
Administrators need to be
able to administrate,
configure the system.
The dispatchers need to be able
to create, assign, and
monitor jobs as they're going
through their life cycle.
The second thing we have
is a mobile UI.
This is for smartphones and
tablets, GPS enabled, that are
ever present in the pockets,
bags, trucks, that the mobile
workers use to do their job.
As the mobile workers are out
there, this is collecting the
GPS information that provides
the real time location
information that we have.
But instead of me standing up
here waving my hands around,
you looking at the screen that's
static, let me show you
some of this in action.
And in order to do that, I
click to the next slide.
And it says demo.
So I'm going to switch over to
device number three here.
And this is a live picture of
Google Maps Coordinate.
Google Maps Coordinate
is a live product
that's available now.
It just recently-- we delivered
it last Friday.
So its paint's just dry.
But it's doing very well.
This is, as I said before,
the web UI.
This is used by administrators
and dispatchers, dispatchers
for creating, assigning, and
monitoring those jobs in
progress, and administrators
to do their administration.
The primary UI here shows the
location of a number of jobs
that we've got on the map.
I could select any of these
jobs or tap on one.
But first, let me tell
you a little story.
The story that I'm going to use
through our demonstration
today is all about
your company.
You, audience, are the owner
of a fantastic premium ice
cream supply company here
in San Francisco.
And your job, as you have
to be attentive to your
customers, is to take calls, get
emails, or understand when
your customers are going to need
more of your specialty
ice creams, and deliver them
throughout the city as quickly
and as efficiently as you can.
Dave and I in this scenario
are going to be your
trustworthy truck drivers
that do the delivers.
Here is a set of jobs that show
the deliveries that need
to be made.
I could click on a pin here or
touch a job to get detail
about this job.
Here I can see who the job is
for, Spear Street Treats--
excuse me--
whether it's assigned, whether
it's been accepted, what stage
of its life cycle it's moved
through, details about the
job, who it's assigned
to, and history
information about the job.
I can change the status
if I need to.
But I don't need to at
this point in time.
Let's go back to jobs.
I could also look at the jobs
that are being worked on today
or, slicing and dicing all
this data a number of
different ways, I can see which
jobs are unassigned.
Luckily none of them are.
I can look at them
by job name.
I can see the job history.
So here's the single job
that we've already
accomplished today.
Dave has delivered to
Google I/O 100 hand
dipped vanilla cones.
I can go back in history
to see jobs
that we've done recently.
So you get both the immediate
information, as well as
information over time.
As I said, the two kind of
organizing concepts that we
have are jobs and the team.
If I switch to look at
the team, I can see--
let's bring this in view
a little bit--
where my mobile workers
are on the map.
I can look at the
active ones now.
This says that we've gotten GPS
information in from those
mobile workers very recently.
If that information is old,
it'll say we haven't had
information for 10 minutes
ago, something like that.
But as of just now means that
we've got live information for
both Dave and I, which is why
we're both here on the map in
Moscone Center.
I can look at all the
mobile workers.
And you'll see there's one
more gray one down here.
That person's probably off shift
right now or not working
at this point in time.
So he does the night shift for
any immediate important night
deliveries of ice cream.
Let's see.
I'm going to switch
back to here.
So we've done teams and jobs.
Those are administrative
roles.
I want to get to one more thing
before we actually get
into assigning a job.
I'm sorry.
Teams and jobs were dispatcher
kinds of things.
I want to get into what the
administrator can do with this.
First of all, the administrator
can attach any
kind of metadata to the
members of a team.
So I just did metadata.
The administrator can
assign roles to
individuals of the team.
This Is straightforward stuff
that you would expect to see.
In this case, Dave is the
only person who can play
the admin role here.
But everyone else on the
team can be either a
dispatcher or a worker.
And lastly, but certainly not
least important-- and I want
to focus on this--
is configuration of the job
information itself.
So far, what you've seen--
Google Maps Coordinate focuses
down this kind of work and
teams information into
just jobs and teams.
But every business has custom
information that they need to
track in order to really deal
with their customers.
So on every job that Google Maps
Coordinate manages, the
administrator can assign
custom fields.
So we can add fields this way.
And this field can be anything,
any data you want
collected during the
process of the job.
The data can be optional or it
can be required in order to
complete the job.
So for instance, what I've
already done in this scenario
is I've already said that every
job has a next order
field in that.
And so when the mobile worker is
delivering three gallons of
peanut butter rocky road
peppermint stick ice cream,
which is tasty, they also have
to fill out that OK, stock at
this shop is good for
three more days.
But maybe after three days, we
want to come back proactively
to try and help this purveyor of
our fine tasty treats sell
our product.
So let me go back at
this point in time.
And let's see what a dispatcher
would really do
during their day.
Let's create a job.
So I'm going to go
to the Jobs tab.
I'm going to click Add a Job.
And this is going to
be Google I/O--
we need 1,000 dipped
vanilla cones.
And we want this--
let's see--
we're going to go
and distribute
these to Moscone Center.
Now as you would expect, from
any Google Maps product, I
just typed in Moscone Center.
And Maps has figured out where
that really is based on the
location, based on all the
information that we have
collected together.
So that's going to go
to Moscone Center.
So this has placed a tentative
pin on my map.
I can pick this pin up and move
it around if that's not
the right place for it to go.
So for instance, where the pin's
shown up is at the main
south building, I think,
for Moscone Center.
And I want to pick this pin up,
and move it over here to
the building where
we really are.
Great.
Now I can assign this job so
that it happens at a certain
date and time.
Or I can assign this job--
I just put it into the queue.
It happens for the worker when
they're done with the current
jobs that they have going.
I'm going to assign this job to
Dave because I'm lazy, and
leave it there.
Now the other thing that I need
to know is that I want
this to go to Moscone room--
we're in room 11, aren't we?
That's what we're in?
Great, thanks.
Let's have it go to
our room here.
OK.
Here's the next order field just
like we had configured.
And that will show up
throughout the life
cycle of this job.
I'm going to click Create Job.
And Dave will be notified
momentarily that this job is
now in process.
So let's look at this a little
bit from what happens
on the mobile UI.
And for that, I need
to come over here.
Sorry.
I'm just typing in my password,
which I don't think
I will project.
Great.
So here we see our smartphone
running Google Maps Coordinate
mobile application.
And very much like you might
expect, this has pins on it
for the various jobs that--
this is my account, Dave,
the truck driver--
pins on it for the various
jobs I need to complete.
And it also shows the location
of other members of my team.
If we weren't distributing ice
cream-- well, let's say we are
distributing ice cream,
and my truck is just
out of rocky road.
And so I need to transfer
a job to Dave
or to someone else.
It might be very, very, very
valuable for me to know who's
in my proximity, and be able to
communicate with them then
and find out who's
got rocky road.
Because I've got a customer who
really needs it right now.
But I can go ahead and tap
on any of these jobs.
And it will give me the job
information that's there.
In this case, I haven't even
accepted this job yet.
I'm going to start working
on this job.
So I'm going to tap Accept.
And this will now change the
job status, now accepted.
The job history is there.
If there were other job details
that the dispatcher
had put in, say nice things
to the owner.
Their dog's name is Fifi.
Any of that information
would be valuable.
That could be here on the job.
I can also, at any point in
time, update more information.
If I already know--
maybe I haven't given them all
the rocky road that they need.
But I already know that
their next delivery
should be on Monday.
I could go ahead and fill that
information in here.
As you might expect, not only
can I get to the jobs that are
interesting to me by
tapping on them.
But I can go list the jobs that
are available for me.
And I can see all
of them there.
In the same way, I can list the
other team members that
are available.
And in the case that Dave
weren't right on my map
somewhere that I could see,
I could tap on him.
And it would show me exactly
where he is.
Now a few other things
about this interface.
Clearly, we're using the
smartphone to collect the real
time GPS location or Wi-Fi
based location
for the mobile workers.
And location and location
information, location history,
is sensitive information and
information that we want to
treat with the utmost respect.
So there's a number of different
things that we do.
I'll get back to one on the
web UI in just a moment.
But the mobile UI always allows
the user to tap this
Visible button down there
in the bottom right.
If they need to step out of
work for a moment for some
reason and don't want to be
tracked, they can turn the
tracking off there.
Secondly, we have the ability
to adjust the
location sharing options.
So if they are in a
scenario where--
let's say the corporate security
scenario that I
brought up earlier.
If there's a corporate security
scenario where the
corporate security team needs to
know exactly where all the
people are right now, we can
give real time information.
But if the kind of work that
they're in that says that a
job is going to take four
hours, and they don't
necessarily want to spend their
battery on updating that
GPS information every five
seconds, they could also set
this to 5 minutes, 10 minutes,
something like that, or stop
sharing in the case that it's
a kind of secrecy issue.
Not secrecy.
Secrecy is the wrong word.
But sensitivity.
A few other things about
the mobile app here.
First of all, when Dave gets to
Moscone Center, which we've
correctly positioned the pin
for, and he needs to know
where to take that ice cream,
we've told him on the job
ticket that he needs to take
it to room 3014, room 11.
Now here, this is a great use
of what we have with Google
Maps with indoor mapping.
So you can see that as Dave
arrives, he can see
what's on level one.
And this should just fill in.
There's not a lot
on level one.
On level two, we have a certain
number of rooms.
He knows he's still not
to the right room.
But if he goes to the third
level, he can see that here is
where 3014 is.
He can even find the bathrooms
after he's done his work.
So Wi-Fi location, indoor
mapping, really fantastic, GPS
based location.
Lastly, Dave mentioned already
that a lot of these mobile
workers are within Wi-Fi
connect range for about
60% of their day.
So what about the other 40% of
the day, very important time.
They're still doing
their work.
The application is set up so
that it's collecting the
information even if it has no
one to send it to immediately,
will keep that information
around, will keep changes
around-- state changes that
they make to tasks--
and update those when they
can get back online.
So the idea is it's a very low
barrier tool for the mobile
worker to be using that provides
terrific information
on efficiency and effectiveness
as well as
what's been completed
to the enterprise.
Let me, at this point in time,
switch back to the web UI.
I get that?
And I wanted to show you one
last thing, another kind of
security and sensitivity
issue.
If we get back to an individual,
I'm going to go
into Dave Owens.
And not only can we see the work
that Dave's got going.
But we have this location
history section down here.
We can switch back and
forth in days.
And I'm going to pull out.
Because we should be able
to see more data.
Oh, we're not seeing
anything today.
You can see blue dots.
I came up on the train from--
No.
DAVE DAY: The other Dave.
DAVID OWENS: There we go.
OK, well it's not showing.
Well, it's showing just a little
bit of information.
Location history's tracked
and is displayable.
And you can look at that
in various different
granularities.
So when you want to go back, not
just know what's happened
today, and what was successfully
delivered and
what jobs were done today, but
you want to know how well we
did over the quarter.
What was the spread?
What was the efficiency
of the trucks?
That's data that's captured
and available.
Now at this point in time, I
know you're saying, hey, Dave.
Sounds great.
Love your work.
Love what you're showing us.
But how does this help
me and my job?
And that's where we get to
interface number three, which
is the interface, the API
programming interface for
Google Maps Coordinate.
And to get to that, I need to go
back to here, pick up this.
This is a little bit
of a review slide.
What does Coordinate
do for you?
Location, communication, job
management tools, seeing all
the assets on your map.
Notification, instant updating,
and the ability to
report and review.
So let's talk about
And to do that, Google
Maps Coordinate API.
So this is primarily
a product.
The API is not the biggest
API you're
going to see from Google.
But it does allow you
to do a couple of
very important things.
It's an OAuth2, REST based API,
very simple to adopt.
And it allows you to essentially
create jobs,
assigned jobs in a team,
and list those jobs.
So the point here is that it's
easy to integrate with
existing systems of some kind--
ticketing systems, CRM
systems, in house systems,
perhaps, that you've got.
If the dispatching and job flow
management functionality
that's available through
Coordinate sounds valuable in
conjunction with some kind of
tool that you know or have,
then we'd love to talk
to you about this.
A couple of quick
examples here.
These should not
be surprising.
Really simple is what
we've gone for.
Creating a job, post a URL,
REST based, we give
you some data back.
You can see that there's an ID
there, the second line of the
response, 16726.
That's the ID that you can use
to talk to us further about
this job in the future.
Assigning a job--
again, hopefully this isn't
too surprising.
It's another post.
You can see in the URL that I've
got a little space there
that says team.
This is a [? GUID ?]
that you will use that
comes from the
team that you've built.
And it's important to have
in the path there.
But it's very easy to get.
So assign a job--
I want to assign a job to me.
And then here we go,
response back.
Lastly, and this is the real
meat and potatoes call here.
It's the getting,
listing jobs.
What jobs do I have open?
There's many variants to this.
But you can ask for what's the
state of a specific job?
So if you want up to the minute
tracking on a specific
job or you can get all the jobs
that have been completed,
say, in the last 24 hours, all
the jobs that were completed
in the last quarter, things
like that, so that you can
build and integrate
on top of that.
My question for you today is
how do you want to use it?
And I'd love to talk to you
either in questions or office
hours, after the session-- any
time you can find me--
about interesting use cases.
Now I love Google
Maps Coordinate.
But I know that it's a product
that's not necessarily the
perfect fit for everybody.
So what do you do if you have
more things to deal with than
Coordinate is necessarily set up
for, if you already have a
significant in house investment
on some kind of
data that just doesn't fit with
the simple API that we
have provided?
And that's where the Google Maps
Tracks API comes in, and
I hand it back to Dave.
DAVE DAY: Thank you.
DAVID OWENS: His is better.
His is better.
Don't clap for me.
DAVE DAY: We'll see.
So like you've heard, the Tracks
API is built on and
leverages that same
infrastructure that Google
Maps Coordinate is built on.
But instead of providing it
and wrapping it up in an
application, instead we provide
you with a raw and
powerful API upon which you
build your own application.
So maybe you need something,
a more bespoke solution,
something customized
to your business.
Maybe, for example, the metaphor
of jobs just doesn't
really fit with what
your business does.
Or you'd like to start
integrating location
information into existing
systems you have.
Or maybe you have another
type of problem.
Your ice cream business
has just gone global.
And you have thousands and
thousands of things you need
to start worrying about.
You have thousands and thousands
of vehicles, or
employees, or packages.
And as you can probably imagine,
if you're sending
location data throughout the
day for thousands and
thousands of things, pretty
soon you're talking about
millions and millions of
points that you need to
record, you need to analyze,
and you need to understand.
And really that's where storing
your location data in
Google's Cloud really comes
through for you.
Because instead of having to
have infrastructure in your
own office, your own server
room, where you are receiving,
processing, storing data,
instead, each of the entities
out in the field--
your workers, your vehicles--
can upload their data directly
to Google's Cloud.
So you don't have to pay
for the bandwidth.
You don't have to pay for the
additional storage, computing
power, to have that location
data stored in your office.
And similarly, when it comes
time to download the data, you
can access the Cloud directly
from your office.
And the Google Cloud is both
geographically distributed and
highly reliable.
So you know you're building
on a solid base.
This also means that how
you're recording your
information and how you're
retrieving it
is completely decoupled.
And it gives you a lot of
flexibility in what sort of
devices you are using
to record.
So the Tracks API is a location
based database.
And there are three main aspects
which we think are
important about it.
The first of these is that
it's very specialized.
It's designed, it lives, and it
breathes for location data.
So it has a lot of concepts
and metaphors that make
working with location data
both easy and natural.
The second is that we have
designed it to be secure.
Because your location data is
both sensitive and valuable.
And the third thing is it's
designed to be scalable.
So as your business grows,
we will cope with all the
additional data that you're
throwing at it.
And lastly, it's a
simple HTTP API.
It talks in JSON.
It talks in XML.
So there's a lot of flexibility
about how you
integrate with it, whether it's
a small embedded device
inside a truck, or a smartphone
application, or a
systems back end, pretty much
anything should be able to
talk to it.
But it's worth pointing out that
it isn't a replacement
for your generic relational
database, maybe your App
Engine Data Store that
you're already using
to keep your data.
It really is designed only
for location data.
And that's where it will
act the most strongly.
And it also isn't an end to end
out of the box solution
like you get with Google
Maps Coordinate.
So just to harp on a little bit
more about the security,
because it's such an important
concept, there are a number of
steps we have taken to make
sure that you can feel
comfortable and confident
that your data is safe.
The first of these is we make
sure that all your data to and
from the Cloud is encrypted
with SSL.
And we also use OAuth2 to make
sure that we know that you're
the person we're talking to.
And therefore, you can be
confident that someone else
isn't accessing or changing
your data.
Once the data hits the Google
Cloud, it's also encrypted
with a key that's unique to
your organization, another
layer of security.
And finally, we have designed
the database to have full
right consistency.
So even though you can be
throwing thousands and
thousands of these updates at
it, you can be sure that one
update isn't accidentally going
to clobber the next one.
So to dive a little bit more
deeply the Tracks API and how
you can actually use it, I'm
going to introduce the first
three building blocks upon which
the Tracks API is built.
And the first of these is an
entity, or, in your case, an
ice cream truck.
But it could be anything.
It could be vehicles.
It could be packages.
It could be people.
The Tracks API doesn't really
care what sort of thing you're
interested in tracking.
The second piece is what we
like to call a crumb.
And a crumb is just a little
piece of data which describes
where your entry was at a
particular point in time.
And when you join your entity
up with a series of these
crumbs, we get what
we call a track.
And a track simply describes how
your entities moved around
the surface of the Earth as
time has gone forward.
So to get started with the
Tracks API, the first thing
you'll want to do is start
creating entities.
And this, like all the actions
in the Tracks API, is achieved
with a simple HTTP post.
So in this case I'm creating two
new entities, Fred's ice
cream experience and The
Susie Soft Serve.
And already this is sort of
highlighting two of the design
decisions we have taken
with the Tracks API.
One is that, wherever possible,
all our methods work
on as many objects as
they can at once.
So here we could be creating
two entities.
We could be creating hundreds.
And that saves you and your
servers a lot of bandwidth, a
lot of processing power.
The second thing is this
use of a name.
The name is any label you'd like
to attach to an entity.
So in this case, I've got a
pretty accurate description of
what I'm sending.
But it could be something like
your vehicle's license plate
number or the idea you're
using within your
own existing database.
It doesn't matter.
Tracks API doesn't
introspect on it.
So whatever you'd like
to use it for.
What is important
is the response.
And that contains the entity
IDs that the Tracks API
[? emits ?] for you.
And use those IDs in the future
when you're talking
about those entities.
So we have an entity.
Now, of course, what we're going
to want to do is start
recording data for
that entity.
And again, a simple post.
Here you can see where we
specified the identity that
we're interested in recording
the crumbs for, and then,
again, a list of as many crumbs
as you'd like to store.
So for example, if you're
driving through tunnels and
you've lost connectivity, you
can batch them up, and send
them all at once.
Or maybe for efficiency reasons,
you only want to send
them every few minutes
or every few hours.
Another very interesting aspect
is that we let you
attach arbitrary data to any
point that you record.
So in your ice cream business,
you're going to want to make
sure your ice creams are smooth,
and fresh, and cold.
And so every time you check in,
you can also record the
freezer temperature.
And then later on, when you're
analyzing this data, you can
maybe identify how can you
optimize the equipment, or the
routes, or the way you your
drivers behave to keep that
temperature low.
And finally, the track.
We've recorded the crumbs.
So now it's time to
get them back.
The simplest way is just to
specify which entity we want
to talk to and what's the
maximum time that we're
interested in.
And then the Tracks API will
return a series of crumbs up
to and including that
time stamp.
So this is great if you just
want to look at what's the
history from now, or you can use
this to page back through
history download everything.
But on the other hand, you might
be more interested in
trying to get a general idea of
where was your truck over
the last week?
And downloading every single
crumb for that entire week
isn't really going to make
that picture any clearer.
You just want the summary,
not exactly when
did they turn left?
When did they turn right?
And so to achieve that, you're
also able to specify a minimum
time stamp.
So you can specify a complete
range, and then also how many
samples you'd like the
Tracks API to return.
And then we'll take an even
sampling across the entire
week, and return you just
that summary done.
Then if you notice something
interesting, you can shorten
the time range and get more
detailed data for that range.
So again, it's helping you be
more efficient in the way
you're retrieving and
analyzing the data.
But most of the time, you're
probably going to want to talk
about more than one
entity at once.
You have hundreds or thousands
of trucks out there.
And you're going to want to know
for example, where are
they all now?
I want to see an up to date
view of the world.
And so we've introduced the
concept of collections
to help with that.
Collections let you talk about a
group of entities at once. .
And one of the main things
they're used for is getting
the live location of everything
in that collection.
Again, the Tracks API doesn't
really care about semantics or
hierarchies in collections.
So you can define them
however you want.
They can be overlapping.
They don't need to intersect--
whatever actually makes sense
for your business.
So in our business, we
know that there are
two important things--
trucks that have sprinkles
and trucks that
play musical sirens.
And so they're the two
collections we're
going to set up.
We don't care that some trucks
might have both, some trucks
might have neither.
It doesn't matter
to Tracks API.
Again, once we create them,
we would get returned two
collection IDs.
And that's what we'll
use in the future.
Setting up collections does
take a second step.
And that's once you've actually
made the collections,
you start adding entities to
it to actually define which
entities are contained
in each collection.
And there are other end methods
too, such as removing
collections and adding
and removing entities
once they're set up.
So we've set up our
collection.
It's simple to see where
is everyone right now.
All you need to do is specify
a collection ID.
And the result is an array of
all the different entities,
one per entity, and for each of
those entities where did we
last see them?
When did they last check in?
So that's all well and good.
But often when you're wanting to
get this location data and
see where things are, you're
actually more interested in
what constraints you have.
For example, you might say, I
want to make sure that none of
my trucks are ever leaving
California.
Because that's maybe where
our license runs out
or something similar.
Maybe you want to know when your
trucks are getting close
to your factory, so you can
be prepared for them.
And so you might set a 10
kilometer ring around your
factory and want to be notified
when your trucks are
getting close.
In Sydney, we have a pretty
notorious area known as the
Gelato District.
And we've lost many a
good ice cream truck
in the Gelato District.
So we just want to
steer clear.
For this we use geofences.
Geofences are essentially
just a polygonal
region on the Earth.
And whether that's the entire
Earth minus a little bit or a
little bit of the Earth, it's
just you want to keep your
trucks within that geofence.
And so, again, creating
a geofence is a
simple post to the API.
It works in the same way that
entities and collections did.
But with geofences, we need one
additional piece of data.
And that's actually what polygon
are we interested in?
And as we saw in the other ones,
once we have created it,
we get minted our own geofence
ID, a new one.
As with collections, when we set
up the geofence, we need
to tell the geofence what
entities or what collections
are we interested in?
So in the case of geofences, you
can monitor more than one
collection at once.
So as before, we specify a
geofence ID and the collection
IDs that we'd like it
to be applied to it.
And finally, when we need to
look up that data, we specify
the collection ID,
and then, again,
get an array of results.
And this time for each result
we'll find one entity, the
geofence that it activated, and
the crumb which was the
offending crumb.
So when did it cross
the boundary?
What was the first
crumb we saw?
And so here we have a simple
way to set up a lot of
geofences against one collection
and then get a
summary of which are
the entities I
should be worried about?
Which are the crumbs that have
caused that alarm to go off?
And in this way get a really
simple quick summary about the
state of the collection.
So those are some of the very
broad brush strokes across the
Tracks API.
We create entities.
You record against them.
And then once you've done that,
you can get historical
tracks or put them in
collections to get live locations.
And then you can also
start to set
boundaries using geofences.
The Tracks API is in an early
developer preview.
So we're still aggressively
building out features.
And what we'd really like to
hear from you is what would
you use something like this
for in your business?
And what are the features you'd
really like to see that
would help you solve
your problems?
DAVID OWENS: Great.
So the question is kind of where
to next, in a sense?
Dave and I are both really
interested in that.
From a Google Maps Coordinate
point of view we have--
Sorry.
Are we on?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVE DAY: Thank you.
We have an I/O special Bitly URL
set up that includes the
opportunity for registering
for some swag.
It's so secret, I don't
even know what it is.
But then our outside
of conference URL,
maps.google.com/coordinate is a
terrific place to go to find
more information.
DAVID OWENS: And likewise, we've
got a short link there
to get you in contact with us
if you're interested in
learning more about
the Tracks API.
We'd be really excited
to hear from you.
And so now if anyone has any
questions they'd like to ask
straight away, we would be more
than happy to field them.
Just step up to the mic.
Otherwise, thank you very
much for your time.
DAVE DAY: And we'll also be--
Sorry.
Not to cut off clapping.
We will also be at the Developer
Sandbox downstairs,
the green Maps podium, for as
long as it would be valuable
for anyone.
But please, questions
if there are.
AUDIENCE: So we just got
done specifying.
And we're about to start
building a logistics
application, basically doing
what you're doing.
There's some features that are
missing that we were including
in our spec.
We're wondering if they're
kind of on your radar.
One was the routing
optimization.
So as you get 10 jobs, and you
assign them to two drivers,
will you be doing like turn by
turn and routing optimization
for those drivers to help them
get from point to point in an
efficient manner?
DAVID OWENS: Well they aren't
in the interfaces
that we've got here.
But those are clearly valuable
features that Google has some
insight on.
And we could talk more
about that offline.
AUDIENCE: The second feature is
to be able to do analytics
over the driver's performance.
So how are they getting from
place to place based on
distances so that we can analyze
their efficiency and
be correcting bad
driving habits.
I don't know if there's
any plans for that.
DAVID OWENS: Yeah, again,
very interesting.
I'd look at that and say, we'd
more likely encourage you to
use the API to get location
information out of the system
and apply analytics yourself
at this point.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thanks.
DAVID OWENS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I would like to ask how much
would the Tracks API cost?
Because I have seen the
Coordinates API.
DAVE DAY: Yeah.
The Tracks API pricings
are still under flux.
But we're looking at the
maximum price of
about $12 per asset.
AUDIENCE: Then another
question would
be could you share--
perhaps Sandbox question, but
what stack did you use to
build the product
like Coordinate?
So what software
would you use?
DAVID OWENS: OK.
I was going to give you the flip
answer and say, to build
Coordinate we use Tracks.
But part of it is with the
application mobile
apps that we have.
So we are using the mobile
stacks for those.
That's obvious.
And then we are using Java
technology for our front
ending and our back ending.
Do you use GWT or some other
JavaScript software?
DAVID OWENS: We're
not using GWT.
AUDIENCE: OK.
OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
way to connect
this to Google Contacts?
DAVE DAY: Yes.
Not explicitly, but definitely
they'll be designed to work
well together.
They will definitely have
similar fields and
authentications through
the API stack.
AUDIENCE: So if I created a
mobile app that my clients'
clients can use to enter some
information, their contact
information could be pulled
in and added to--
DAVE DAY: Right.
That would be a manual step on
your end rather than something
that we'd do.
But yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Through the API.
DAVE DAY: Yes, yep.
DAVID OWENS: I'd follow that
up by saying that from the
Google Maps Coordinate point of
view, certainly, as I said,
we're a young application in
that we've just been released.
But there are many integrations
with other parts
of the Google infrastructure
that we'd love to see.
AUDIENCE: Can I just ask what
kind of scale you're thinking
of for the application that
you're demonstrating?
Obviously, Google scales big.
But are you scaling big too?
DAVID OWENS: We'd love to.
We'd love to, absolutely.
I think the place that we're
seeing the most feedback right
now from early customers is not
on the scale of the 10,000
member teams, but smaller
than that.
Now the truth is it's
still a Google app.
It's operating at
Google scale.
And it's operating
at global scale.
So we have our geo data
all around the world.
And there's no reason why we
can't be looking at teams that
are tens of thousands large.
AUDIENCE: What about tens
of thousands of jobs?
DAVID OWENS: Oh, jobs, sure.
No worries.
I mean we have to deal with that
because of job history.
It's a new tongue.
Even if it's a small team, that
team could be dealing
with hundreds of jobs a day.
And over time we'd need to
be dealing with many,
many, many, many jobs.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Catch you later.
DAVID OWENS: Sure, thank you.
That's a terrific way to build
interest in the question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was going to ask about the
asset tracking licensing that
exists today.
We are a reseller.
And we sell Maps
implementation.
So there's an asset tracking
scale that we have.
Does this replace all the old
asset tracking products?
DAVID OWENS: That's a great
question that I don't have a
good answer for.
DAVE DAY: I've got someone to
chat with after if you'd like
to come and learn a bit
more about that.
Yeah.
DAVID OWENS: Great, thank you.
DAVE DAY: Great.
All right.
Well, it looks like that's it.
Thank you very much
for your time.
And I hope it was helpful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.